يا ترى عناصر حزب العمال الكردستاني
ووحداته حمايه الشعب الكرديه يرفعون العلم
الامريكي احيانا والعلم السوري في احيانا
اخرى لحمايه انفسهم
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم القوات التركيه تقصف
تجمعات لما تعرفوا بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه في رفي حلب والحسكه رئاسه
التركيه اكدت للجزيره ان المسلحين الاكراد
اهداف مشروعه سواء كانوا قرب الحدود او
بعيدين عنها من جانبه طلب الفصيل السوري
المسلح المجتمع الدولي بالتدخل لوقف
الهجوم التركييه والتواصلي لحل سياسي
الرئيس الاسرائيلي يصل الى البحرين في
زياره رسمي هي الاولى من نوعها ومن المقرر
ان يعقد اجتماعا سياسيا مع ملك البحرين
ويلتقل الجاري الاسرائيليه قبل ان يتوجه
الى الامارات ويجتمع مع رئيس الدوله
بيحاسب الرئاسه
المدعي العام الايراني وقفه عمل سلطه
الاخلاق بقرار من الجهات التي انشاتها
ويؤكد ان السلطاته تبحث مساله الحجاب
ستعلن النتائج خلال اسبوعين لايجاد حل
مدروس و التعامل مع ظاهره عدم رعايه
الحجاب التي ازعجت الجميع بحاسب تعبير
الفيفا يعلن احصائيات الدور الاول
لمونديال قطر ويقولون ان الدور المجموعات
الشاهده حضور جماهيريا تاريخيا فاق
مونديال روسيا كما استضاف ملعب لوسيل
العدد الاكبر من الجماهير في تاريخ بطوله
كاس العالم بلغ نحو
99,000 مشجعا في مباراه الارجنتين
والمكسيك
الى اللقاء